i want to start first with what you
think the issues with the current social
networks are so we've got twitter we've
got facebook these are obviously
massive massive multi-billion dollar
companies uh we're literally using some
of them to communicate on a daily basis
what do you think the big challenges
with them are like what are they where
are their missteps
yeah well this is the funny thing pomp
is that if you look at social media
today it's actually more centralized
than the financial system was before
bitcoin i mean you know like literally
think about it right you have five
companies that virtually control
everything we see and do online and
we're over here trying to decide which
billionaire we want to censor us you
know it's it's you know who's gonna own
twitter zuckerberg owns facebook already
um but pomp you know you guys know the
real answer which is that we want nobody
in charge right we want to own our
information like we own our bitcoin and
that's something that people really
aren't talking about you know like it's
funny because the solution to
centralization in the financial system
uh wasn't to put warren buffett in
charge of money right it was to use
technology namely bitcoin uh to
completely overhaul it and decentralize
it um and so you know for what we think
is basically the same overhaul is needed
in social and we think that blockchain
is the answer there too uh and the
reason it hasn't happened yet uh we
think is because uh we basically still
need to scale blockchain tech to be able
to handle storing content uh not just
moving money around so those are very
different problems right so just for
example it costs 80 to store a 200
character post on ethereum it costs 25
cents to a dollar on solana avalanche
polygon you know that's not low enough
to compete at scale with twitter
instagram and facebook uh but if we
could then we could really change things
we could actually make it so that uh you
can own your content like you own your
bitcoin
um yeah so when you think when you think
about these problems how much of it is
censorship versus there's other issues
that are playing out like like the the
censorship thing is very obvious i think
people understand that and and control
is kind of interfaced with that uh are
there other things or is it just let's
get rid of the censorship
well that that's the interesting thing
pomp is uh when you decentralize
something um you actually unlock the
ingenuity of everybody all over the
world rather than a small group of
people running a top-down or centralized
organization so just to give you an
example right uh you know when you got
ethereum going and you let anybody
like build on top of that open financial
platform you got more innovation in defy
in like two years than probably like the
last 50 years in finance right um and so
that's really what putting content on an
open platform on a blockchain does is
now instead of having
one company or five companies really
that that are in charge of building the
feeds uh you can actually have anyone in
the world spin up a social app and their
own social feed with extremely low
barrier to entry because they have
access to all of that content they can
build a feed without having to go and
acquire a billion users in order to be
competitive so essentially it lowers the
barrier to entry to creating a social
app which not only gives you a lot more
choice when it comes to moderation like
who do you want to moderate uh but it
also leads to better apps better
experiences uh better everything um and
so you're absolutely right it's a
problem of unlocking the entire world's
potential right and moving really moving
from centrally planned uh development of
social apps to uh decentralized
development which i think can be a lot
more efficient hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time